good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 35 object class
Keter special containment procedures SCP
35 is to be kept within a hermetically
sealed glass case no fewer than 10
centimeters thick this case is to be
contained within a steel iron and lead
shielded room at all times
doors are to be triple locked at all
times with the exception of allowing
personnel in or out no fewer than two
armed guards are to be posted at any
time guards must remain outside at all
times and are not allowed within the
containment room under any circumstances
a trained psychologist is to remain
on-site at all times research personnel
are not to touch SCP 35 at any time SCP
35 must be moved to a new sealed case
every two weeks the previous case must
be disposed of via SCP 101 as it shows
no adverse reactions to SCP 35s
corruption anyone who comes into contact
with a CP 35 when it is in possession of
a host is to be given an immediate
psychological evaluation description SCP
35 appears to be a white porcelain
comedy mask although at times it will
change to tragedy in these events all
existing visual records such as
photographs video footage even
illustrations of SCP 35 automatically
changed to reflect its new appearance a
highly corrosive and degenerative
viscous liquid constantly seeps from the
eye and mouth holes of SCP 35 anything
coming into contact with this substance
slowly decays over a period of time
depending on the material until it has
decayed completely into a pool of the
original content
glass seems to react the slowest to the
effects of the item
hence the construction choice of its
immediate container living organisms
that come into contact with the
substance react in much the same way
with no chance of recovery origin of the
liquid is a known liquid is only visible
from the front and does not emerge Shore
is even visible from the other side
subjects within one point five to two
meters of SCP 35 or in visual contact
with it experience a strong urge to put
it on when a CP 35 is placed on the face
of an individual an alternate brainwave
pattern from a CP 35 overlaps that of
the original host effectively snuffing
it out and causing brain death to the
subject subject then claims to be the
consciousness contained within scp-1305
accelerated rate eventually becoming
little more than mummified corpses
nevertheless SCP 35 has demonstrated the
ability to remain in cognitive control
of the body experiencing severe
structural damage even if the subjects
body literally decays to the point where
motion is not mechanically possible no
effect is found to be had when placed on
the face of an animal conversations with
a CP 35 have proven to be informative
researchers have learned various details
about other SCP objects and history in
general as SCP 35 claims to have been at
many monumental events as CP 35 displays
a highly intelligent and charismatic
personality being both amiable and
flattering to all those who speak with
it a SCP 35 has scored on the 99th
percentile on hall intelligence and
aptitude tests administered to it and
appears to have a photographic memory
however psychological analysis has
discovered SCP 35 to possess a highly
manipulative nature capable of forcing
sudden and profound changes to
interviewers psychological state
as CP 35 has proven to be highly
sadistic prompting some to commit
suicide and transforming others into
near mindless servants with linguistic
persuasion alone SCP 35 has stated that
it has intimate knowledge of the
workings of the human mind and implied
that it can change anyone's views if
given enough time
additional SCP 35 was found sealed in a
crypt in an abandoned house in Venice in
18th addendum 3501 SCP 35 has been found
to be able to possess anything that has
a humanoid shape including mannequins
corpses and statues SCP 35 has been able
to motivate all into movement removing
the need to expose live subjects to SCP
35 still anything it possesses
inevitably decays into motionlessness
addendum 3502
SCP 35 has facilitated an escape attempt
convincing several of the research staff
to aid it in its bid for freedom
insurrection failed all staff that have
been in contact with us EP 35 have been
terminated and mandatory psychiatric
evaluations have been implemented for
all personnel coming into contact with
SCP 35 addendum 3503 it has been
determined that SCP 35 is capable of
telepathy whether or not it possesses a
host even penetrating to the
subconscious of others and using the
knowledge it finds to its advantage
extreme caution is advised when choosing
subjects to converse with SCP 35
addendum 3504 SCP 35 has expressed
interest in other s eps most notably SCP
47 15 and scp-682 dr has expressed worry
that should a CP 35 bond with either
their regenerative qualities would
negate its corruption and give it a
permanent host
addendum 3505 after several more escape
attempts after reviewing SCP 35 s
incident record High Command has ordered
that it be permanently sealed within the
facility and prohibited from being
allowed any more hosts the several
personnel have protested against this
with some even erupting into violence as
a direct result all personnel that have
come into contact with SCP 35 have been
terminated going forward all personnel
that deal with SCP 35 are to be rotated
frequently and contact is to be limited
even to its dormant state to as little
as possible addendum 3506 personnel
within 10 meters of SCP 35 have recently
reported feeling unease stating that
they can hear unintelligible whispering
several others have suffered from severe
migraines object has been monitored but
there is no change in its dormant
behavior and no sounds have been
recorded the motion to reinstate SCP 35
s host privileges has been brought up
once more if only on a temporary basis
to discover these new changes in the
object's behavior denied addendum 3507
the walls of SCP 35 s containment cell
have suddenly begun secreting a black
substance tests on the substance have
revealed it to be human blood although
highly contaminated with several foreign
and unknown agents substance is
corrosive having a pH of 4.5 and
prolonged exposure to the walls has
proven to be detrimental to their
structural integrity more notably it
seems to be forming patterns on the
walls several segments seem to be
paragraphs in various languages
including Italian Latin Greek and
Sanskrit translation is pending
other segments appear to be diagrams
depicting ritualistic sacrifice and be
relation often for the arcane benefit of
the person committing them several staff
members have been shocked to note that
all of the sacrifices bear an uncanny
resemblance to various personnel and
their loved ones often in conflicting
positions researchers while in the room
examining these newly formed patterns
have complained of hearing loud
whispering and high-pitched unnerving
laughter at irregular intervals
personnel in the section working daily
near and around the CP 35s containment
unit have suffered catastrophic morale
damage with an all-time high in suicide
rates and staff in that area whether or
not they have ever had contact with SCP
35 the only change in as CP 35 dormant
behavior is regarding its contained
glass case degradation of the case has
increased to a high degree enough so
that the glass will occasionally shatter
causing a wide dispersal of SCP 35s
contaminant this occurs quite often at
the most inopportune times so far
resulting in six casualties and three
fatalities of both research and cleanup
staff addendum 3508
in light of the mass suicide and
homicide of the members of the research
team tasked with translating the
passages garnered from SCP 35s
containment cell the morale damage in
the area and general loss of staff
dealing with SCP 35 to either death or
insanity it has been decided to coat the
inner and outer walls of its containment
cell with SCP 148 which has proved well
in the containment of scp-1325
negativity being emitted by SCP 35
addendum 3509 the use of scp-144 al and
suicide rates to return to near pre SCP
35 rates however material appears to
facilitate the negativity within its
cell causing a veritable greenhouse
effect inside personnel inside the cell
have stated that they feel a heavy sense
of dread fear anger and general
depression as well as hearing a constant
nearly inaudible whispering upon
immediate entry a prolonged stay causes
severe migraines suicidal tendencies
heavy hemorrhaging of blood vessels
around the eyes and inside the mouth and
nose general hostility to others and for
the whispering to increase to almost
deafening volumes intersected by
constant mocking laughter exposure of
more than three hours inevitably results
in the subject falling into a deep
psychosis and attempting to harm either
themselves or others most spoke Latin or
Greek despite the fact that several did
not previously know how to speak said
languages before head
the presence of blood in both word and
diagram formations has increased
disproportionately the walls becoming
cluttered and the formations beginning
to overlap each other the substance has
proven to be both difficult to clean and
even more corrosive than was originally
recorded with a pH of roughly 2.4
general estimation gives the current
walls a life of two months before they
will need replacement it is becoming
gradually more and more difficult to
contain a CP 35 and the debate to
reinstate its host privileges as once
again come up denied
addendum 35 10 the walls ceiling and
floor of SCP 35 s containment cell have
now been completely saturated in blood
all personnel entering and guarding the
area must wear full hazmat protection
suits constant cleaning efforts are
being in stated addendum 35 11 the
magnitude intensity and reoccurrence of
the phenomena that occur within SCP 35 s
containment cell have increased to an
alarming degree the cell door has been
known to become locked of its own accord
while personnel are inside and unable to
be opened for a period of time
appendages form out of the larger
puddles of blood and often attempt to
grab or harm personnel near them
blurry apparitions have started
appearing to staff electronic devices
now no longer work inside the cell and
the light cannot be turned on though
there is no physical reason why it
doesn't work
forcing those entering to use non
electric based light sources cleaning
measures are having no discernible
effect on the cell and the walls are
degrading in a very high rate forcing
them to be replaced within a week at
best
although the blood makes it nearly
impossible to properly achieve this a CP
35 may have to be moved to a new cell
entirely with the old one sealed off and
disengaged from the rest of the facility
okay I think that about does it for
today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to the Morrigan mr. blue up
Jim's Sabha arbiter Sewell it's not a
spoon Darius Tom art Thomas Justin day
and jayvo Jack Cory Barker Chloe Harlan
summer Ike corgis and Nathan if you
would like a special thank you at the
end of each of my videos on some other
cool stuff as well visit patreon.com
forward slash the volcan thank you